if we could find a universe in which  there was more antimatter than matter  would we be able to detect it would be  able to distinguish it and then the  question of whether or not this universe  could be taken as not having opposite  charges but having an opposite time  coordinate that's the subject of this  paper this paper created so many  headlines back in 2018 that we had to  have on dr abby vireg who worked on the  anita project which seemed to suggest  according to the new york post that  there was a multiverse now the  multiverse has many different garbs  multiple multiple universes there's the  ever ready and many worlds hypothesis  universe what does it all mean is it  just hype come along in this voyage into  the heart of reality and the meaning of  time and space itself  [Music]  [Applause]